[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
beaucoup d'entre nous voudraient pouvoir
manger des animaux mais sans les faire
souffrir est ce que c'est possible
de l'autre côté on voudrait remettre en
cause notre façon de nous alimenter
depuis plusieurs millénaires et cela
sans nous faire souffrir
est ce que c'est possible le débat entre
les spéciste et les antispécistes de
beaux jours devant lui
il se nourrit de tout ce qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui l'écologie le
respect de la vie le refus de la
souffrance les inégalités la justice les
rapports de domination pour qu pourquoi
aurait-on le droit de tuer des animaux
et pourquoi non non on en aurait-on pas
le droit
l'animal est il une personne comme les
autres autant de questions auxquelles il
n'est pas toujours facile de répondre
pour en débattre nous avons invité jeu
c'est une porsche et vous êtes une
figure de lentilles anti spécisme zoo
technicienne sociologue directrice de
recherche à l'inra où vous dirigez
animal slam l'équipe qui s'intéressent
au travail des animaux vous avez publié
en 2014 un livre blanc pour une mort
digne des animaux est votre dernier
essai s'intitule cause animale cause du
capital il est paru l'année dernière aux
éditions du bord de l'eau je saigne
porsche est pourquoi êtes-vous anti
antispécistes je suis pas anti
antispécistes je pense que c'est c1 ce
sont des théories qui à mon sens sont
pas beaucoup de pertinence et donc non
je perds pas mon temps être anti
antispécistes ce que j'essaye de montrer
c'est l'importance de nos relations aux
animaux la richesse de ce qui nous
apporte et c'est donc de convaincre les
antispécistes de voilà deux des pistes
qu'il manque dans leurs démarches et
dans le raisonnement en face de vous il
va y avoir ou plutôt à côté david chauve
et vous vous êtes du côté des
animalistes juriste chercheur à
l'institut européen des droits de
l'homme
votre dernier livre s'intitule une
raison de luttes et les paru à l'âge
d'homme
on peut le trouver dans les collections
de poche pourquoi êtes-vous animalistes
bien si vous entendez par un humanisme
le simple fait de se soucier des animaux
et d'avoir
quelques égards vis-à-vis de leurs
souffrances ou de leur vie ben je suis
animalistes mais je pense comme la
plupart des gens en filaments qui ne se
soucie pas des animaux à degré ou un
autre
donc je crois que les raisons qui
m'anime en tant qu'animal y sont
fondamentalement les mêmes que celles
kahnisme la plupart des gens avec
peut-être une gradation différente en
tant qu antispécistes par rapport à
quelqu'un par exemple qu'ils mangent de
la viande
alors la question la première question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est peu
peut-on manger des animaux
peut-on manger de la viande peut-on
manger des oeufs du fromage sans les
faire souffrir
est ce que c'est possible je suis mort
chez oui c'est face est tout à fait
possible les uns
je pense que c'est ce que font des
éleveurs depuis des milliers d'années
c'est le problème moi je dirais qu'on
mange pas des animaux en mangent de la
viande issue des animaux on élève des
animaux aux fenêtres on tue des animaux
mais après on mange pas des animaux
mangent de la viande issue d'un bain de
l'animal de la carcasse animal c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose un animal
c'est un être vivant et la viande
commandes videmment l'animal justement
il est mort pour qu'on puisse manger
s'avérant donc c est le problème donc
c'est pas voilà effectivement c'est
celui que vous mettez en relief c'est la
question de la souffrance est donc entre
une légitimité qui lie à l'élevage à
tuer les animaux à les élever à les
faire naître à lecce en chine et c'est
une chose après la façon dont on tuer
les animaux
la passion d'ailleurs donc entendre elle
traite aussi dans les systèmes
industriels c'est là qu'est la question
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on avait travaillé
avec mon équipe là sur l'abattage des
animaux donc on avait produit le livre
donc dont vous avez parlé la livre blanc
pour une mort digne des animaux cesser
la question c'est ça c'est comment
éviter toute souffrance aux animaux et
durant la période d'élevage la période
louis vivent avec nous et travailler
avec nous et où 1 - de leur abattage et
c'est tout à fait possible
là je travaille depuis plusieurs années
sur des solutions d'abattage à la ferme
etc
pour éviter justement l'abattoir et
éviter comment les les
les failles c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire des systèmes d'abattage des animaux
donc liés à l'industrialisation de
l'élevage
david on peut continuer de manger de la
viande des oeufs du fromage sans frères
souffrir les animaux bien je crains que
non nous sommes il ya 3 millions
d'animaux qui sont tués tous les jours
en france pour produire de la viande
ces animaux oui quand on mange de la
viande en mange des animaux en mangent
du porc mangent du boeuf on mange des
animaux ces animaux qui sont produits à
une telle échelle industrielle ne
peuvent que souffrir dans les élevages
intensifs 4 la grande majorité des
élevages sont des élevages intensifs et
dans les abattoirs avec les gars dans ce
qu'on connaît qui ont été révélés par
l'association l214 pour que les animaux
souffrent moins pour qu'ils aient moins
de souffrance animale dans l'élevage tel
qu'on le connaît actuellement et je ne
parlais pas donc de végétarisme de gens
il faudrait que la consommation
individuelle de viandes diminuent
drastiquement
c'est la seul moyen de mettre un terme à
l'élevage intensif et c'est le seul
moyen aussi de d'alléger les cadences
dans les abattoirs et donc il ya moins
de souffrance animale dans les abattoirs
et c'est un point je pense qu'il
faudrait débattre ce soir et j'ai
toujours un certain étonnement a
constaté que je suis une porsche et
s'oppose à tous ceux qui veulent
diminuer leur consommation de viande si
elle souhaitait à être cohérente avec
elle-même c'est parce que je sais
qu'elle est ou el far east et qu'elle
est qu'elle souhaite que les animaux
souffrent moins dans les dents dans le
système actuel
eh bien il devrait plaider pour une
diminution massive de la consommation de
viande donc elle devrait plaider pour
l'élève égales pour les végétariens pour
la viande in vitro pour tout ce qui peut
faire baisser
cette consommation massive monumentale
de viande je fais une planche et est-ce
qu'on peut continuer de manger autant de
viande sans faire souffrir les animaux
donc en leur évitant l'élevage
industriel par exemple
enfin la la la question est vite réglée
c'est à dire moi je depuis que j'ai
commencé à travailler dans dans un
élevage et peu après dans les
productions animales dont les systèmes
industriels pour st voilà j'ai j'ai
travaillé à la fois en tant que
chercheur et en tant que citoyens à
lutter contre ces systèmes industriels
et donc j'ai montré je pense que
d'ailleurs je suis à peu près la seule
sociologue avoir montré à quoi
ressemblait travail dans les porcheries
industrielles j'écris à plusieurs
plusieurs livres sur le sujet et donc
montrer la violence contre les animaux
la violence contre les personnes la
souffrance au travail l'inanité tout ça
dans l'obscénité tout ça donc voilà la
critique des systèmes industriels la
porte depuis longtemps depuis plus de 20
ans à l'époque d'ailleurs c'est pas du
tout à la mode et et je pense que voilà
tout ça n'intéressait pas grand nombre
de savoir que les cochons souffrait un
système industriel
pas plus que les travailleurs du reste
mais donc enfin une grande partie de mes
recherches et de montrer ça c'est que
ces systèmes industriels ils ont rien à
voir avec l'élevage l'élevage un rapport
historique de travail avec les animaux
qu'à différentes rationalité alors que
les psy ces systèmes industriels ils ont
qu une seule raison d'être c'est de
faire de l'argent
donc ça n'a rien à voir ces deux mondes
différents de monde voilà dans deux
temporalités différentes de rationalité
différentes cetera donc si quand je
peins d'élevage au parc d'élevage
tanière d'un des gens qui élève les
animaux qui vivent et travaillent avec
eux de façon respectable après les
systèmes industriels
oui bien sûr non seulement il faut à à
diminuer la consommation de produits
issus de l'industrie mais il faut même
arrêté il faut il faut arrêter ces
systèmes et enfin je ne dis pas je ne
dis pas de plus récents je le dis depuis
20 ans et ses systèmes industriels sont
ignobles et donc le meilleur des choses
à faire pour un consommateur c'est de ne
pas acheter ses produits issus des
systèmes industriels et donc forcément
si à la place de ces de la viande casher
de systèmes industriels pas cher parce
que les coûts sont externalisés
la personne en question achètent des
produits issus de l'élevage ils sont un
peu plus chers pas forcément d'ailleurs
en tout cas beaucoup plus nourrissants
donc il aura besoin de moi manger
effectivement changer de fournisseur on
va dire ça ça fera baisser effectivement
drastiquement la consommation de biens
issus des systèmes industriels il faut
pas enfin moi mon propos c'est pas de
dire arrêtez de manger de la viande fait
un lundi sans viande etc s'est arrêté de
manger de la viande des produits
d'ailleurs des yaourts des laitages
issues des systèmes industriels et
préférez les produits d'élevage et
soutenez les vaches paysans acheter des
produits de l'élevage paysans les
biocoop dans l'est dans les magasins bio
de chez les éleveurs eux-mêmes par
internet etc
et là ça fera des c'est évidemment la
consommation de viande issue des
produits des systèmes industriels c'est
celle là qu'il faut faire baisser c'est
celle là qu'il faut condamner et et là
on pourrait faire quelque chose
d'efficace david chauvet vous considérez
que les animaux issus de l'élevage pas
industriel de l'élevage souffrent - ou
ne souffre plus du tout ça m'étonnerait
les animaux qui sont élevées dans les
élevages que soutient ce juste une
porsche et et qui sont effectivement
préférable aux élevages intensifs
finissez l'abattoir donc de toutes
façons ils connaissent sept morts au
minimum il connaît cette mort violente
qui est celle qu'on leur réserve dans
les abattoirs
je rappelle quand même que le l214 a
épinglé des pratiques de souffrance
animale dans des dans des abattoirs bio
pour la viande bio par ailleurs
je pense que je suis une personne n'a
pas répondu à l'interpellation que je
lui ai fait parce que encore une fois
de deux choses l'une soit on mange les
mêmes quantités de viande et l'élevage
sera industrielle soit on diminue notre
consommation durable donc est-ce que je
suis une porsche et veut dire quand elle
dit qu'il faut payer un peu plus cher
qu'il faut manger moins de viande
parce que si on doit manger autant de
viande ça se terminera fatale ça ne
changera pas le système tel qu'il est je
pense que on peut s'entendre a su ne
serait-ce que les cadences dans les
abattoirs puisque il 3 millions
d'animaux tués tous les jours dans un
abattoir vous pouvez bien imaginer que
ça ne se passe pas de manière entre
guillemets humaine et que ça conduit
forcément à des violences sur les
animaux les gens ne le voient pas parce
que les abattoirs n'ouvrent leurs portes
involontairement je dirais qu'à
l'occasion des vidéos comme celle de
l214 principalement celles de l214
mais je pense que si on avait un accès
aux abattoirs et si on sent des comptes
de de ce qui s'y passe dans derrière ces
portes closes
peut-être qu'un certain nombre de
personnes comprendrait que la violence
c'est quelque chose de réel pour les
animaux dans les abattoirs et donc
peut-être que on se dirait qu'il faut
repenser la consommation viande au
minimum on l'a 10 millions drastiquement
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
david vous vous confierez qu'il ne peut
il n'y a pas de mort digne des animaux
je pense que si vous considérez cas
l'animal à une mort digne parce qu'il se
fait tuer pour faire de la viande jeu
vous demande si vous aimeriez avoir
cette mort digne jocelyne porcher pense
que c'est une mort digne
bon c'est son opinion en jeu la combat
j'estime que la dignité il nous est une
notion très précise c'est un concept qui
n'est qu'on peut pas tordre dans tous
les sens la dignité d'un être humain et
comprend certains droits fondamentaux et
de même si les animaux doivent avoir une
existence digne ça ne peut pas appliquer
le fait d'être tué pour envoyer pour
être pour être envoyées sous forme de
pièces détachées dans les supermarchés
donc il faut ne faut pas tordre les
termes et les conseille dans tous les
sens
la dignité ne peut être accolé au fait
de tuer un animal pour le manger le
faire pencher
je pense que ces cds comme cdd des
questions difficiles 1-1 débattre quand
quand on replace pas la relation à
l'animal donc dans toute la longueur de
sa vie c'est à dire si on fait un focus
sur sur la mort de l'animal évidemment
enfin même que ce soit de l'abattage à
la ferme dans les systèmes industriels
bien davantage évidemment mais même si
on prend l'abattage à la ferme en dehors
de tout ce qui a fait le lien et la vie
de travail entre les éleveurs et les
animaux et le fait que des humains qui
ce qui somme omni va évidemment on
comprend rien salaires les éleveurs ne
tue pas les animaux pour le plaisir y
tuent les animaux pas tous d'ailleurs et
pas forcément enfin je veux dire c'est c
c'est une des possibilités de la sortie
du travail des animaux c'est pas la
seule il y avait les animaux qu'il va
qui n'iront jamais à l'abattoir
née en même temps simplement là elle
prend sens justement parce que on vit on
travaille avec les animaux parce que bon
je le dis brièvement parce que c'est ça
serait un peu long mais c'est les
systèmes d'élevage c'est un système
finit donc c'est un endroit où on fait
naître des animaux et comme il ya des
ressources de manière fini 6ème qui
naissent fauqué des animaux qui partent
ça c'est commencer le béaba de
l'histoire et d'autre part l'autre b à
ba c'est que on est des êtres niveau
qu'on mange de la viande mais pas
seulement la viande c'est pas le
problème d'ailleurs le derrière le
délire derrière le podium où il ya aussi
de la viande d'ailleurs le petit fromage
de chèvre ya aussi de la mort des
animaux
donc il faut prendre les choses de
manière globale et il se dire que cette
cette morale un sens dans le cadre du
travail avec les animaux et cela depuis
dix mille ans et parvient pas de
l'inventer ça fait dix mille ans on vit
qu'on travaille et que les animaux qu'a
vécu un produit des aliments et qu' une
partie des animaux un âge où un autre
est abattu pour nous alimenter quand
nous nourrit un essai c'est un problème
est pas là le problème
et comme on élève les animaux est ce
qu'on les élèves d'ailleurs où est-ce
qu'on est produit comme des choses est
derrière est ce qu'on leur donne une
mort digne c'est à dire un spectacle
pour eux et pour nous ou est ce qu on
les transforme comme des choses comme
c'est le cas dans les systèmes
industriels c'est ça l'enjeu maintenant
la mort des animaux
elle a un sens pour les éleveurs
d'ailleurs quand on est éleveur
évidemment on fait rentrer cette mort
des animaux les sources général de notre
travail
alors justement vous l'avez dit ça fait
dix mille ans que c'est comme ça peut-on
remettre en cause notre manière de nous
alimenter depuis dix mille ans
et que cela se passe de manière calme et
raisonnée sans déchaîner les passions
david sauver plus de révolution que vous
attendez vous espérez que vous demander
ce qu'on mange c'est très très important
on est ce qu'on mange
il ya de la procès m'a giclé dedans oui
oui ma première chose je voudrais
insister sur un point qui me semble
important parce que on voit souvent la
question l'antispécisme soul animalistes
comme une sorte de l'uby apparues
récemment et qui serait comment dire
délire de bobos des villes et c'est vrai
d'abord insisté sur le fait que la
question de la légitimité la de
l'alimentation carnée elle est vieille
comme l'histoire de la philosophie c'est
à dire vous trouvez des philosophes dans
l'antiquité porphyre plutarque et c'est
qui déjà condamné la consommation de
viande et il trouvait en face d'eux un
peu comme ce soir des gens pour
légitimer la consommation de viande donc
là le débat sur l'alimentation carnée
est consubstantielle à la civilisation
occidentale et même à d'autres
civilisations
je pense par exemple à l'islam qui a eu
le débat des beaucoup de débats aussi là
dessus mais restons sur la question donc
de nos pays
là je le répète la question de
l'alimentation carnée est une question
qui est vieille comme 2 2 qui traverse
de toutes les époques en remontant
jusqu'à la grèce et bien au delà donc
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose
effectivement vous avez raison constater
que c'est une véritable révolution dans
les pratiques alimentaires si on est
habitué depuis plus plusieurs milliers
d'années à manger de la viande et que
demain on s'en passe
oui c'est une révolution mais ce ne sera
pas la première en sont peut-être
d'ailleurs pas la dernière non plus
peut-être d'autres évolutions mais en
tout cas on a pratiqué l'esclavagé
pendant des millénaires aussi et à un
moment on ya mis un terme
donc oui ça peut entraîner des
crispations ça peut entraîner des débats
très passionné enflammé dn
non mais je crois que c'est pas quelque
chose qui doit nous surprendre c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait normal et
ça fait partie aussi du pluralisme et de
la démocratie de pouvoir débattre de
manière si possible apaisé de toutes ces
questions là je crois c'est ce qu'on
fait ce soir on échange des arguments et
puis chacun se fait son opinion je sais
me pencher penser que ça peut être à
débat calme tranquille oui ce soir bien
entendu mais mais mais quand la société
traversée par ce débat là on voit on
sent bien que ça la remue
considérablement
oui c'est pas un débat anecdotique parce
qu'il ya des enjeux extrêmement fort
mais juste je voudrais juste revenir sur
le fait que que david chauvet centre son
propos sur l'avion au scotch jeudi c'est
justement que c'est pas la viande le
problème il ya pas que la viande
là y'a pas que la viande qui entraîne la
mort des animaux
il ya aussi justement tous les produits
laitiers les oeufs etc
c'est important parce que quand on
promeut le végétarisme comme c'est le
cas dans nos sociétés avec des jets
tarissement nicole végétarisme
le végétarisme ne change rien du tout à
la condition des animaux ce qui
changerait la condition des animaux
c'est de choisir l'élevage plutôt que
les productions industrielles mais être
végétarien ne pas manger de viande
et puis prendre des jeux issus de
l'industrie et puis des fromages blancs
issus de l'industrie mais qu'est ce que
ça change pour les animaux rien les
poules pondeuses iront à l'abattoir
de la même façon donc le problème c'est
pas la viande les produits animaux
mangent et à partir voilà des animaux
toutes sortes de produits notamment dès
lors évident à mansle et je le lait les
produits laitiers fromages et bien voilà
ici il faut vous plaindre tout ou rien
parce que alors lien justement c'est là
c'est la commencer la proposition vegan
est là elle est logique dans ce conte
sans fondement c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ils ne veulent rien
devoir aux animaux donc il ne mange rien
qui vient des animaux pas de cuir pas de
miel pains etc
c'est logique c'est un c'est malheureux
mais c'est logique
par contre là comment les enjeux qui a
derrière effectivement c'est pas juste
un petit débat et c'est pour ça que
c'est alors violent oui je pense que
enfin moi je vois personnellement vu les
attaques subies de la part des
animalistes aider vegan sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis longtemps donc oui c'est
violent et et les enjeux sont sont
importants parce qu' il peut y portent
sur nos relations aux animaux c'est à
dire que la proposition en fait anticipé
si ce qui d'ailleurs est déjà celle de
peter singer en 75 c'est au fait
d'arrêter nos relations domestique avec
les animaux donc ce qui est en jeu c'est
pas seulement je vous la viande je mange
pas de viande etc
c est ce qu'on va vivre avec des animaux
c'est le titre de nos bouquins que j'ai
écrit que s'appelle vivre avec les
animaux une utopie pour le 21e siècle et
c'est exactement ça c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est est ce que vivre avec les animaux
maintenant c'est une utopie un lieu où
l'on n'arrivera plus jamais ou est ce
que c'est
ou est ce que c'est encore possible ça
et c'est ça la vraie question que je
voudrais avec elle je n'aurais que mes
concitoyens répond c est ce que on veut
vivre avec des animaux encore ou pas et
si on veut vivre avec des animaux il
faut en mesurer toutes les conséquences
et pas la mode aux polices avec des
petites histoires à dormir debout deux
communautés
comment d'animaux citoyens qui laquelle
la vraie question c'est le travail est
ce qu'on continue de vivre et travailler
avec des animaux avec avec la
possibilité de la mort des animaux mais
savait pas dire et les éleveurs comment
sont pas des fanatiques de la mort des
animaux si on peut voir des alternatives
à la mort des animaux évident que c'est
intéressant n'empêche qu'il y aura
toujours des animaux qui rompt
l'abattoir me même s'il y en a le moins
possible de la meilleure façon possible
en aura toujours donc la mort des
animaux aller mais d'ailleurs l'amour
animaux des chiens aussi de tous ces
animaux qui vont chez le vétérinaire
pour une euthanasie
à la fin de leur vie ou pas quelle à la
mort des animaux elle est
consubstantielle à notre vie avec eux il
faut la penser faut l'assumer il faut un
définir collectivement les modalités
mais l'a refusé
en fait s'ils refusaient à long terme la
vie avec les animaux dans un premier
temps avec les animaux de ferme et
ensuite avec tous les animaux xi a
aucune raison entre guillemets
d'exploiter de ne plus exploiter des
vaches d'exploiter les chevaux après
depuis exploiter les chevaux mais
d'exploiter les chiens enfin bref voilà
l'animal domestique
il est un c'est à dire que ce soit il
s'agit d'une bâche d'accouchement d'un
cheval ou d'un chien d'un chat ce sont
des animaux domestiques la centralité ce
qu'on a montré dans mon équipe de nos
relations avec eux c'est le travail donc
c'est ça qu'il faut interroger qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui fait qu'elles travaillent
font six animaux avec nous dans quelles
conditions et c'est pour ça que les
débats sont violence et que cette
question du travail extrêmement
politique assez des questions de société
c'est à dire la loi ce que je défends
est peut-être qu'on en parlera puisque
david chauvel défend la viande in vitro
c'est des projets de société des projets
de politique voilà l'élevage c'est un
artisanat par exemple c'est l'inversé
il reste trois minutes avant la pause et
on va aborder effectivement toute cette
question à la deuxième partie mais
j'aimerais que david chauvet réponse
vous êtes bien d'accord effectivement
que ça n'est pas de devenir végétarien
qui serait une révolution
une véritable révolution ce serait qu'on
cesse à la fois deux manger les animaux
de laitue et de les exploiter de l'usi
t'utiliser de toutes les manières que de
les exploiter donc de toutes les
bannières que d'en être propriétaire de
les libérer donc de leur rendre et de
leurs comptes
et forcément par la même occasion de
leur donner une partie de nos
territoires pour qu'ils puissent y vivre
c'est ça la révolution la vraie la
grande oui mais je veux quand même
compte un point qui me paraît quand même
sur lequel je suis penché passé un peu
vite elle dit c'est la même chose que
qu'on soit végétarien ou non finalement
parce que si on n'est pas légal c'est la
même chose non si pendant un repas vous
mangez de la viande et des oeufs bayal
il ya là la lia les poules pour l'offre
et la vache pour la viande qui sont tués
donc quelqu'un qui est végétarien vous
me faites pas croire qu'ils ne diminue
pas la masse des animaux tués
évidemment moi je préfère que les gens
soient végétalien mais je pense que les
pubs la plupart des gens ne sont pas
prêts avant milan peut-être de devenir
végétalien donc qu'elle soit que je suis
une porsche et se rassurent par contre
effectivement elle le souligne la vraie
alternative je crois pour les pour les
pour la question animale et pour la
question de la consommation de produits
animaux en général
donc au delà de la viande que ce soit
pour le lait etc c'est effectivement la
viande in vitro qu on examinera après
pour ce qui est de aussi d'un autre
point que sur lequel j'aimerais revenir
c'est là l'idée que effectivement je
suis une porsche et mais ce problème en
avant depuis très longtemps et il est
pas c'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut
éliminer d'un revers de main c'est la
question de savoir est ce qu'on va se
séparer complètement du règne animal
c'est à dire des animaux à commencer
donc par les comme elle le disait par
les animaux d'élevage et on finirait
jusqu'à jusqu'au chiens etc faut savoir
qu'effectivement c'est ce que prônent
certains antispécistes franz hierl par
exemple est ce qu'on appelle un
extinction liste il souhaite qu'on n'ait
aucune relation avec les animaux y
compris les chiens et les chats parce
que selon lui cela ils sont d'une saute
une sorte de situation de dépendance et
ça ne peut à la fin en tant qu ils sont
qu'ils ont des propriétaires ne
s'appellera toujours en leur défaveur
leurs intérêts sont toujours bafoués
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais il
faut savoir que cette position est
minoritaire dans le mouvement animaliste
elle est très débattue mais je suis
marché a évoqué le livre aux polices une
tentative parmi d'autres de penser à un
avenir sans rupture avec le monde animal
je crois que c'est pas vraiment un bon
argument que de que de dire que si on
opte pour le végétarisme le véganisme la
viande in trop il n'y aura plus
d'animaux et on sera complètement
séparée du monde animal ça c'est une
c'est une décision distincte
certes les animaux ne sont plus
exploités dans le cas capitaliste qui
actuellement le nôtre qui les fait il
faut dire les choses
il est réduit à de simples ressources
mais je crois que si on regarde les
choses en face n'est pas une perte
terrible de dire l'élevage intensif
l'élevage au niveau où il est si demain
il disparaît je crois que ce sera pas
non plus une catastrophe qui reste des
animaux qui leur est suffisamment pour
maintenir cette cette relation que les
humains avec les animaux depuis des
millénaires ça je crois que c'est tout à
fait compatible avec un projet
antispécistes en tout cas c'est ma
position et je crois que beaucoup
d'autres la partage on fait une pause et
on continue ce débat et on évoquera
d'ailleurs est-ce que effectivement on
va vers un monde où l'homme se sépare
des animaux pas on l'abordera dans la
deuxième partie
[Musique]
notre débat continue avec jocelyne
porcher qui est aux techniciennes et
sociologue directrice de recherche à
l'inra qui a publié cause animale cause
du capital aux éditions du bord de l'eau
et david chauvet qui est juriste
chercheur à l'institut européen des
droits de l'homme
c'est l'auteur d'une raison de luttes et
qui est disponible à l'âge d'homme en
collection de poche pourquoi pourquoi
aurait-on le droit de de posséder des
animaux de l'est de laitue et de les
manger
pourquoi aurait-on le droit sur quoi
cela repose et pourquoi n'aurait-on plus
le droit aussi la question en fait l'une
découle de l'autre david chauvet
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'aurait plus le
droit et à vous je suis une porsche et
pourquoi aurait-on le droit lequel ces
lentilles david savoir si ben écoutez je
me pose la question pourquoi on n'aurait
pas le droit d'exploiter les humains
pourquoi on pourrait pas avoir des
esclaves
ces questions à ceux sans poser depuis
depuis toujours posé la question du
droit c'est surtout se trouver des
justifications pour pouvoir avoir la
conscience tranquille et se dire
finalement je ne commets pas de
d'oppression de domination de violence
sur les animaux quand je les traite
comme des ressources
donc je crois que c'est ce sont des
débats disons moreau qui qui souvent
dont la principale fonction d' essayer
de légitimer de faire si vous voulez de
faire taire c'est la voix chacun a en
nous la voie de la compassion qui fait
que quand on regarde des vidéos de ce
que 214 ou d'autres on peut pas être
totalement insensible normalement quand
on voit les maltraitances sur des
animaux diverses dans les faits divers
qu'on constate régulièrement
normalement la plupart des gens ne sont
pas insensibles c'est pour ça que je
disais qu'on est tous un peu animalis
d'une manière une longue s'il
animalistes c'est se soucier des animaux
et de ne pas les tenir pour de simples
équivalent de 40 de carotte qui crient
quand on leur fait qu'on leur porte des
coups je pense donc si une si les
animaux ont des droits c'est pour les
mêmes raisons que les humains ont des
droits c'est parce qu'ils ont
une sensibilité ils ont un intérêt à
vivre leur vie pourrait continuer avant
qu'on décide de l'écourter en plus de
manière violente
tout ça fait que normalement il n'est
pas illégitime je crois de soutenir une
position comme la nôtre c'est tout à
fait conforme aux disons aux valeurs
communes ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
s'écartent des valeurs communes
simplement on tire les conséquences et
jusqu'au bout de ces valeurs communes
si vous n'aimez pas tuer un chien pour
le manger bombe a priori devait
réfléchir aussi à la question de savoir
s'il est bien de tuer une vache ou un
cochon voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
mais au-delà de ces questions sur la
légitimité de la consommation de viande
qui se posent encore de jeu le rappel
depuis des millénaires et j'en vois ceux
qui s'intéressent à la littérature sur
le sujet elle est abondante
je voudrais insister sur un point c'est
que de toute façon
au-delà de la question se dire
animalistes il y à la question de
l'impact de la consommation de viande
sur la planète et la planète ne va pas
pouvoir supporter que ça nous plaise ou
non
la consommation de viande à une échelle
globale c'est à dire que tant que ce
sont les les pays dits riches enfin et
qui consomment de la viande la viande la
terre le supporter mais très très
difficilement et sans doute très
provisoirement mais je peux vous assurer
que le jour où les pays émergents et la
chine l'inde etc vont se mettre à
consommer de l'a2 à consommer de la
viande comme comme le nul prévoit
puisque en 2050
la consommation de viande est censé
augmenter par deux je crois que tous ces
débats moraux seront périmées et que je
peux vous assurer que les gens verront
la consommation de viande avec un peu
moins de tranquillité qu'on peut le
faire actuellement
mais d'ici là on verra aussi le fait de
prendre l'avion de monter dans sa
voiture
peut-être même de travailler dans une
usine on verra certainement d'un oeil
très différents
restons donc aujourd'hui sur les
problèmes déjà nombreux que ça nous pose
et notamment celui que je mentionnais
pourquoi at on le droit de
de tuer des animaux pour pouvoir les
manger
sachant que vous citez très souvent les
vidéos de l214 mais la chasse déjà
l'homme ne chasse plus que pour se
distraire depuis des millénaires
il n'en a plus la nécessité depuis qu'on
a inventé l'élevage et si on disait aux
gens que désormais pour pouvoir manger
de la viande il va falloir qu'ils tuent
eux mêmes les animaux je pense que ça
les dissuaderait considérablement
et pourtant même si on n'a pas envie de
tuer les animaux nous mêmes on admet
qu'on puisse les tuer et c'est et c'est
là que la question je voulais vous poser
je suis penché sur quoi ça repose
qu'est ce qui nous permet de nous de
nous satisfaire de l'idée qu'on tue des
animaux pour les manger et que c'est
comme ça je pense que la première des
raisons en fait c'est le sentiment et ça
s'entend beaucoup quand on discute avec
des gens que on est des animaux comme
les autres vous sans la plupart des gens
ne sont pas spécifiques parce qu'ils ont
le sentiment qu'on est des animaux et on
est en élevage c'est très fort le fait
vivre avec les animaux donne donne le
sens d'une communauté de destin avec les
animaux et le sentiment très vif que on
est aussi vulnérable que et qu'on ait
des animaux aussi comme eux et ça
n'empêche pas ni de créer des liens ni
de tuer les animaux parce que là comment
là c'est pas une question de droit voilà
c'est une question d'histoire des
relations je pense que ça se comprend
par rapport à la domestication à ce
moment là la vraie question c'est pas
est ce que j'ai le droit de tuer les
animaux pain c'est pourquoi on vit
ensemble plutôt que séparés pourquoi
pourquoi la domestication c'est ça la
vraie question est est ce cette
conférence que je considère comme
quelque chose
enfin c'est que sept secteurs rencontre
des hommes avec certaines espèces
animales de l'espèce humaine avec
d'autres espèces animales le fait que
depuis dix mille en effet des choses
ensemble des choses extraordinaires
notamment parcourir le monde avec les
chevaux pour commencer s'habiller se
nourrir observer les animaux pour
apprendre énormément de choses cette
rencontre extraordinaire avec les
animaux c'est commencer la source d'une
dune co-évolution complètement
différente de ce qu'elle aurait pu être
enfin on peut imaginer ce qu'elle aurait
pu être si on n'avait pas rencontré les
animaux qu'est ce que l'humanité serait
devenu sans les animent cette rencontre
avec les animaux et donc si on pense les
choses comme ça et qu'on se dit que oui
c'est une ré une rencontre d'espèces et
donc que ces espèces ou font elles elles
ont un intérêt à la domestication qui
est différent qui est différent ou son
blog d'ailleurs parce qu'il y avait
question alimentaire en un petit souvent
les mêmes et bah c'est là qu'on voit que
du coup comment la question de la mort
des animaux elle s'intègre là dedans
pour moi c'est pas une question de droit
c'est une question de sens des choses
c'est à dire ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
viens avec les animaux on leur donne
naissance déjà c'est quelque chose de
très fort ça parce que la vie cette vie
en élevage on donne la vie aux animaux
c'est nous qui donnons la vie c'est nous
qui les élevons signes qui les soigne on
sait une qui les protège dents etc et et
c'est ce que j'ai écrit par ailleurs
c'est tout ça s'inscrit à mon sens dans
un dans un rapport de dos et 2 contres
dos à la fois du point de vue d'un
éleveur unique et dernière fois du point
de vue de nos relations collectives avec
les animaux et donc 7
c'est dans ce cadre là que on peut dire
qu'on a le droit de tuer les animaux
parce que rentrer dans un
une histoire longue où les animaux sont
à la fois nos compagnons de vie est une
ressource alimentaire parce que on est
des hommes niveau parce que alors david
chauvet écarte facilement la question du
végétarisme je n'écarte pas parce
qu'elle est fondamental c'est à dire que
même si on s'est fait manger de la
viande on continuerait de tuer des
animaux
ça c'était extrêmement important et donc
on n'est pas comment omnivore par décret
on est au niveau ronen biologie
d'omnivore donc et on le sait le leur et
un régime sans animaux il ne tient pas
donc il ne tient pas son complémentation
donc il est nécessaire d' voilà donc
cédé ce n'est pas une question de droit
c'est une question de sens de la
relation on veut vivre avec des animaux
et bakel pris ça pour les animaux et
pour nous parce que derrière nous
évidemment il ya un poids il ya un poids
comme en morale d'aider il faut il faut
il faut s'organiser avec ça
individuellement collectivement
et a subi lors des années nous faut pas
le nier c'est un bien pour un animal de
tuer un animal non c'est la condition
collective de notre vie ensemble et nous
travaillons sans depuis les minots david
chauvet c'est vrai que si demain on sait
c'est de tuer les animaux pour les
manger
si on sait c'est de les exploiter pour
fabriquer des vêtements de faire des si
on cessait de faire des expérimentations
animales
si on s'essaie en plus de les posséder
là je parle des animaux de compagnie si
on les libérait donc c'est vrai que ya
de grandes chances qu'il n'y est plus du
tout des animaux qui va encore laisser
des chantiers à des des vaches qui ne
nous servent plus à rien c'est à dire
qu'ils ne sont plus utiles en rien qui
ne sont plus rentables
c'est sûr que le jour où on interdira la
corrida les disney taureau de sauvages
disparaîtront on va pas laisser des
hectares à des animaux que l'on
n'utilise plus en rien même chose pour
les chevaux si on ne les montrent plus
si on ne parie plus aux courses
si les cirques sont fermées il y aura
plus de chevaux vous n'allez pas vous
voiler la face on savait bien que si les
idées des antispécistes de triomphe les
animaux disparaîtront dans leur grande
majorité j'entends il y aura des
réserves quelque part où ils vivront en
liberté comme en afrique aujourd'hui il
ya des réserves pour les lions mais
c'est tout et bien non je n'insiste ce
départ parce que la consommation de
viande et d'autres produits animaux
disparaîtra que ces animaux
disparaîtront pas de sens parce que si
vous voulez ce sont des deux décisions
distinctes
si vous décidez de comment dire de
d'introduire les animaux du pour
d'autres finalités dans la société ul
que la viande et des risques on l'a tout
simplement vous vous dites vous parle
vous commencez par dire qu'il ya on
commence par ailleurs mais on finit par
les chiens avaient encore je vous ai dit
ça c'était une position très minoritaire
c'est parce qu on abolit la viande qu'on
va depuis avoir de chien par exemple
vous parlez des chevaux oui je connais
des gens qui font de l'écu de
l'équitation qui sont antispécistes
alors certains antispécistes vont se
plaindre
enfin moi je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient
du moment que c'est dans une relation
qui est équitable
sans violence et c'est bon je sais que
c'est souvent pas le cas mais on peut
concevoir que ça puisse l'être on peut
concevoir un monde animalistes
antispécistes dans lequel ils devront
pratiquer l'équitation et que ça ne
poserait pas de problème est en tout cas
les problèmes s'ils s'imposaient serait
réglé bon donc il ya mille façons
d'intégrer les animaux pour d'autres
finalités que l'abattoir que dont
jocelyne porcher elle-même à l'instant
dit que ce n'est pas bien pour l'animal
et sa de la thur on peut au moins
s'accorder je crois aussi que à 10 ans
que vous dites ces animaux on ne les
verra plus et les met les gens voit-il
ces animaux simplement je veux dire la
grande l'immense majorité des no vous ne
les voyez pas ils sont derrière ddd des
bâtiments d'élevage intensif
d'accord vous supprimez tous ces
bâtiments vous ne ferez vous ne verrez
pas la différence à vous verrez juste
moins de camions passaient vers les
abattoirs c'est tout donc encore une
fois le peu d'animaux en proportion
lalanne la minorité d'animaux qui sont
élevés dans des conditions non
concentrationnaire le pourrait tout à
fait je crois que c'est parfaitement
concevable pouvoir pourrait parfaitement
exister d'une autre manière pour
d'autres finalités dans nos sociétés je
flippe pencher penser que non mais on
est d'accord sur cette histoire
d'animaux industriels d'être maltraités
par l'industrie s'est on peut on peut
très bien enfin il faudrait et on sait
moins c'est mon voeu le plus pieux
depuis cher depuis depuis tout le temps
de voir ces systèmes industrie
disparaître et il dit
ce sujet effectivement d'accord tous les
deux et la plupart des gens sont
d'accord il faudrait que là ça fait
partie des excès que tout le monde est
d'accord pour gommer mais en même temps
il faut bien se dire qu'on a aboli
toutes les frontières qui se dressait
autrefois entre les races du moins ce
poste qu'on appelait des races entre les
religions entre les hommes et les femmes
entre les hétérosexuels et les
homosexuels
est ce que est ce que les animaux ne
sont pas les prochains sur la liste
ce serait logique aujourd'hui ça s'étend
à tout ce qui est vivant et les animaux
nous ressemble comme des frères vous
l'avez dit nous sommes des animaux nous
mêmes donc il est logique de les faire
rentrer à leur tour leur faire profiter
d'un certain humanisme ce qui veut dire
de cesser de les faire souffrir de
cesser de les manger ne cessez de les
tuer et vraisemblablement ensuite de
cesser de les posséder et de cesser de
les exploiter de quelques manières que
ce soit je crois y compris c'est la
logique même de monter dessus et de les
charger comme des bulles
avec des sacs ou de leur faire labouré
deschamps si on commence on ne
s'arrêtera plus non oui mais je je je
persiste à vous dire que le fait de
faire de l'équitation dans des
conditions respectueuses
ce n'est pas mettre un terme à
l'équitation n'est pas un projet
antispécistes vraiment il faut qui remet
les choses cibler un certain moment
l'armée les oies mais les filles
remettre les priorités si vous voulez
les gens iliad je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure il ya 3 millions d'animaux qui
sont tués tous les jours en france et
dans des conditions épouvantables sans
compter les élevages intensifs contre 2
consacre tous a condamné ici voilà c'est
ce problème c'est ce problème là qu'il
faut regarder en face et cesser si vous
voulez de de polluer je dirais le notre
regard sur ces questions par des
considérations
est ce que tous les animaux
disparaîtront et ce qu'est ce que si
est-ce que ça commençons déjà par on va
se mettre d'accord là dessus si on se
mettait d'accord pour dire déjà que
l'élevage intensif doit disparaître ça
ça veut dire qu'il faut manger
énormément moins de viande c'est du
concret c'est pas des considérations
philosophiques au le métaphysique donc
et je moi ce que la question que je pose
à jocelyne porcher sait si vous êtes
d'accord pour mettre un terme à
l'élevage intensif vous êtes d'accord
pour que les gens mangent moins de 20
ans je ne pouvais pas échappé à ça et
donc vous devriez poussé dans cette voie
là mais c'était faire pousser
sérieusement c'est à dire à la fois par
exemple demander aux gens par exemple
les flexitariens de manger moins de
viande féliciter les végétariens a
félicité les vega fait pousser même la
voie de la viande in vitro pousser tout
ce qui peut conduire à une diminuation
une diminuation énorme parce que
l'élevage intensif énorme de la
consommation de viande et je crois que
c'est vraiment sur ces questions
pratiques là qu'il faut se tourner parce
que s'ils voulaient on te faire des
débats philosophiques ça fait duré toute
la soirée il y a
j'en suis tout quelque chose qui me
passionne mais aussi comprenez que pour
les animaux c'est pas une discussion
philosophique qui se font massacrer on
peut appeler ça un massacre 3 millions
par jour et il faudrait aussi un moment
regarder ces questions ou de la dea des
ornières idéologique des uns et des
autres je dirai ce que je suis
antispécistes est-ce que je suis anti
antispécistes est-ce que je suivais
gagner ce que je suis anti vegan
regardons la réalité des animaux en face
il ya quand même tous les jours je le
répète en france 3 millions d'animaux
tués ils viennent pour la plupart des
élevages intensifs et ils se font passer
moi l'expression ils se font casser la
gueule dans les abattoirs
très souvent les vidéos qu'on a qu'on a
pu voir en témoin ajoute déjà joue cela
venir que pour ma part j'ai plaidé pour
la vidéosurveillance dans les abattoirs
et que évidemment les éleveurs n'en
veulent pas les abattoirs n'en veulent
pas pourquoi parce que ça gêne parce
qu'on ne veut pas voir la réalité de ces
lieux effectivement où les cadences sont
telles que vous allez avoir de la
violence tout le temps de la violence
sur les animaux combien d'animaux à
l'heure où on parle là sont en train de
se prendre des coups de ce on a vu des
choses quand même assez choquant très
choquant
donc voilà voilà ce que j'ai ce que
j'aime
s'il devait faire passer un message ce
soir ce serait de dire ce sont des
discussions philosophiquement
intéressante c'est de ces tours des
débats poli passionnant mais on
s'enferme derrière ddd des étiquettes
antispécistes antispécistes etc et on
oublie un peu les principaux concernés
les animaux eux mêmes et c'est ça que
j'aime qu'on voit ce soir
en effet mais à ce moment là je voudrais
pas vraiment aidé ma liste je vais dire
de vouloir fermer les abattages les
abattoirs qui pratiquent l'abattage
intensifs
la sp à sa date du 19e siècle bien être
des animaux
l'idée qu'il meure dans la dignité tout
ça ça existait déjà au 19e siècle
on n'a rien inventé à ce moment là ce
qui est nouveau c'est l'animal isme
c'est de dire que les animaux sont des
personnes comme les autres ça c'est
nouveau mais si ça consiste juste à ce
qu'on mange moins de viande ou quand tu
moins d'animaux
mais qu'on continue des tués quand même
reconnaissez que cela n'est pas très
nouveau et pas très révolutionnaire
je répète que même la question l'animal
listening l'antispécisme au sens large
elles datent de l'antiquité puisque des
gens se sont battus pour la pour écrit
on fait des traités est juste sur ces
questions de la ville de la légitimité
de l'alimentation carnée il disait que
les tuent les animaux est un meurtre
c'est le terme qu'ils employaient qu'il
faut pas manger les animaux vous trouvez
ça chez porphyre plus tard que les
excités
pour ce qui est attention comprenez moi
bien je ne dis pas que je ne
souhaiterais pas qu'on ne tue compte
qu'on cesse de tuer tous les animaux
c'est à dire tous les animaux qu'on
exploite que ce soit pour la corrida de
chasse viande en général ce que je dis
simplement ce que je dis simplement
c'est fait pour moi je parlais je
voulais je voudrais sortir de ces débats
un peu théorique pour arriver sur la
question pratique vous dit à l'instant
oui ce n'est pas nouveau les élevages
on a toujours condamner les excès et là
maintenant les élevages intensifs tout
le monde s'accordent à dire que bon
c'est quelque chose qui devrait
disparaître très bien mais personne ne
fait rien pour et je crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui va compter
qui peut continuer comme ça allègrement
sans aucun problème si on ne prend pas
des mesures contre ça y est je veux dire
que c'est des questions politiques qui
doivent se poser mois par an j'ai
proposé de taxer la viande pour diminuer
la consommation de viande est ce que je
suis une porsche et est pour ou contre
si elle est contre eh bien ma foi ça
veut dire qu'elle veut que la viande
continuent au même niveau au ciel et
pour que la viande continuent au même
niveau elle est donc pour que les
élevages intensifs continuent au même
niveau
j'ai encore une fois je le répète
personnellement je souhaiterais que les
animaux cesse d'être tué tout court
mais il ya au moins ici quelque chose
sur quoi on peut s'accorder
c'est que les élevages intensifs qui
concerne je le rappelle la grande
majorité des animaux ces élevages là
devraient disparaître
et ça veut dire prendre des mesures
concrètes donc poussé au végétarisme le
lundi vers bassam ça va dans ce sens
poussé au véganisme bien sûr poussé à la
une taxe sur la viande est poussé à
d'autres alternatives comme la viande in
vitro
je dire un certain moment c'est ces
questions concrètes là qu'il faut
affronter et se dire est justifié
comment on peut d'un côté être contre
les élevages intensifs
puisque je pense qu'on va pas se mettre
d'accord ici jossinet moi si vous voulez
sur
si on de tuer ou pas les animaux en
général c'est pour ça que je me
concentre sur ce qui peut nous accorder
sur c'est là qu'on peut avoir un débat
intéressant j'ai fait bon donc de nom la
borne la fois être contre l'élevage
intensif et ne ne soutenir aucune
initiative qui permet de mettre fin à
l'élevage intensif c'est à dire à
diminuer le niveau de consommation
énorme que connaît actuellement je fais
une porsche et oui bah je vais répondre
sur plusieurs points premièrement moi je
parle pas d'élevage intensif intensif ça
veut rien dire intense intensif sa porte
sur un des éléments de des facteurs du
travail ça peut être intensifs en espace
intensifs on travaille dans six camps de
choses on en est ainsi que ça veut rien
dire ce dont il est question c'est les
systèmes industriels et la souffrance de
l'animal elle vient du fait qu'on le
traite comme un objet industriel c'est
ça le problème vous bien employer les
bons mots déjà
deuxièmement parce que c'est de
l'industrie s'est pas d'élevage donc
élevage industriel c'est un oxymore
quand vous parlez des systèmes
industriels a dit système industriel on
comprendra bien de ce dont il s'agit de
traiter les animaux comme des choses
industrielle de leïla leïla et la
violence d'ailleurs les 100 gr dans une
porcherie industrielle souffrance de
l'animal elle commence à sa naissance et
finit à l'abattoir donc on est bien
d'accord là dessus ces systèmes
industriels
ça fait 20 ans que je le dis même plus
de 20 ans il faut les jeter y sont
ignobles ils sont obscènes c'est une
honte pour l'esprit humain et notre
humanité une relation d'animaux on est
d'accord là dessus
après moi je dis que ça ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'élevage l'élevage c'est tout
autre chose c'est un rapport de travail
avec les animaux sont pas ceux concédés
au début mais les jurons qui pousse
il faut taxer la viande par exemple il
faut taxer non mais et voilà mais c'est
pour que je réponde à ça il faut que je
leur dise qu'ils ne sais pas qui a deux
mondes différents et taxer la viande
industrielle oui et la taxe est très
très fort même la voilà en faire un
objet in achetable mais par contre taxer
la viande et les produits je le redis
pas seulement la viande mais il faut
taxer les yaourts si on taxe la viande
ne cesse la viande en soit c'est c'est
pas le sujet je le redis c'est on peut
pas parler de la viande sont parlé du
yaourt donc taxer les produits animaux
issus des systèmes industriels oui oui
très fortement allez-y faites des
propositions
taxer les produits d'élevage non au
contraire il faudrait que les produits
d'élevage soit on pourra
j'ai installé des élevages paysans et
que tous ces éleveurs qui font des
produits respectueux des animaux
justement à ise a des avantages
comparatifs
comment un avantage en termes de prix
donc ça maintenant
l'autre chose que je voulais souligner
c'est que je suis très étonnée qu'on ne
puisse être antispécistes et à faire de
l'équitation faudrait savoir
parce que le cheval qu'on monte c'est un
animal d'élevage il a été élevé
il a été il ay là il est approprié
quelqu'un a décidé de sa naissance donc
c'est je pense que les beaucoup d'anti
specis qui s'arrange pas ce qu'on veut
faire de l'équitation les antispécistes
en même temps ah bah tiens on va
théorisé que c'est possible de faire
l'aller l'autre non vous êtes
antispécistes la relation d'équitation
plus le cheval c'est vraiment une
relation extrêmement forte d'autorité
avec les animaux donc quand on est
anticipée si ça paraît très bizarre
d'assumer cette relation d'autorité
envers le cheval c'est très étonnant et
à ce moment là si on tolère l'équitation
pour le loisir
pourquoi ne pas la l'autorisé pour la
course camarguaise et pourquoi pas le
taureau à ce moment là et pourquoi pas
d'autres animaux s'étaient c'est assez
surprenant et pas très court iront donc
je crois que c'est ça le problème c'est
de proposer des théories de poser des
théories qui tiennent pas compte du réel
de nos liens avec les animaux la plupart
on a besoin des animaux c'est pour ça
que je soulignais cette soeur de co
évolution tout à l'heure le fait que
cette domestication la domestication la
relation domestique avec les animaux
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
quelque chose qui n'a qui nous a fait
naître à nous mêmes qui nous a construit
notre humanité et c'est pour ça qu'en
fait c'est très ce projet antispécistes
il est très difficile à tenir
c'est qu'en fait on a envie d'être avec
les animaux n'a envie d'avoir un chez on
a envie de monter à cheval etc raïs et
l'opl et le comment une articulation
entre théorie et pratique du coup ça ne
tient pas et donc faut arranger la
théorie pour dire ma que c'est
compatible de de faire du dos d'âne être
antispécistes de dire qu'il n'ya pas que
la le rapport d'autorité le rapport de
l'autorité de l'humain sur animal n'est
pas légitime bat vraiment alors là avec
le cheval si c'est pas un rapport
d'autorité et même jeu pour pas dire de
me nations et les histoires histoires
l'équitation va dans ce sens là quand
même même si là personnellement je
travaille décoller sur la relation des
relations de travail avec les animaux
qu'on décrit en termes plutôt d'autorité
que de domination ça n'empêche pas que
c'est voilà c'est un rapport où il y en
a un qui décide et l'eau qui obéissent
et c'est ici et c'est la halle comment
c'est là le point le plus difficile à
assumer dans nos relations aux animaux
c'est qu'elle est asymétrique
voilà il faut l'assumer oui bien sûr ccc
lecavalier karine au centre est qui dit
arba - tiens je montais machin et tiens
je vais faire du cpi voilà c'est pas le
cheval qui dit tiens bon tiens toi je
vais vous bien que monde sur mende ou
non c'est une relation asymétrique où la
suite réponse de david chauvet alors
première chose je suis une porsche et
veut séparer élevage intensive élevage
extensif en dix ans finalement le seul
élevage qui mérite digne de ce nom c'est
l'élevage extensif mais ça vous ferait
croire c'est comme dire que les animaux
qu'on mange
enfin c'est pas des ennemis on mange de
la viande on mange des animaux s'ils
voulaient sa cdc des habiletés de
langage pour essayer de préserver
l'élevage de la gueule dit traditionnel
de la critique bon voilà je tenais à
relever ce point maintenant
de la même façon al'inverse je suis le
marché et c'est finalement 2-2
d'enfermer lentilles specif dans une
cohérence qui serait une cohue une
cohérence dans laquelle on couperait
toutes les relations et finalement à
dieu vous n'êtes pas cohérent donc vous
n'êtes pas antispécistes donc je vais
très clair de la lune par mois je ne
suis pas là pour défendre l'antispécisme
l'animal isme je suis là pour défendre
les animaux mois les étiquettes je le
répète antispécistes animalistes etc
je n'en ai strictement rien à faire ça
comme ça vous met à l'aise sur ce point
si demain dans les conditions actuelles
les l'équitation évidemment c'est un
rapport de domination j'ai discuté
l'autre avec une personne qui me parlait
de qui était de cibler de l'intérieur de
ces pratiques et qui me racontait à ça
c'est absolument abominable les gens
derrière l'image d'epinal de
l'équitation on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
de violence
ce que je dis simplement c'est que c'est
concevable
un monde dans lequel on pourrait faire
j'ai pris cet exemple on a pu en prendre
d'autres de l'équitation sans violence
vous allez faire croire à personne que
l'équitation ça se termine forcément
rapports de domination ou d'autorité ou
tout ce que vous voulez je pense que ça
c'est totalement faux c'est une vue de
vue de l'esprit il faudrait demander aux
professionnels si demain on me demanda
des professionnels est ce que
l'équitation oui ou non est possible
d'une manière civiles égalitaires pour
parler plus facilement et qu'il réponde
hui je dirais très bien assez parfait et
s'ils ne le disent non et baron dire en
supprime d'équitation mais je crois
qu'on pourra dire oui
alors arrêtons de parler ciblées sur des
abstractions je crois que le plus
important c'est de dire
fondamentalement le fait de vouloir
lutter pour que les animaux ne se fasse
pu tuer ou massacrés ou torturés dans
les laboratoires d'expérimentation à la
corrida ou tout ce que vous voulez et où
les élevages intensifs
ça ne veut pas dire ça ne veut pas dire
contrairement à ce que certains essayent
de faire passer ça ne veut pas dire
couper les ponts avec les animaux ça ça
des toutes relations avec les ennemis du
elle termina élus dans un cadre
égalitaire c'est tout merci tous les
deux d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]